so if today you got a call
is there a dollar amount that would get
you to entertain fighting straight up
with khabib if he was also open to a ufc
card like full on the same way you
fought all these years would you
entertain a fight today with khabib no i
would not zero no zero 10 million bucks
zero it's nothing that can thirty
million bucks yeah i don't care
seriously yeah tell me why i can have a
credit card that can i can use for the
rest of the would you wanna do that with
anybody no because no nobody and i'm
gonna tell you why there is no price for
my health and i'm not only talking about
physical health
i what took the most out of me during
my active years of competition
competition it was the stress i had a
lot of stress and i always told myself
because it's an addiction you become
addicted to this thing it's like a drug
winning especially winning a title
winning a fight it's
it's crazy man i can't describe
how it makes you feel but it can become
an addiction